STEPHAN DE BARSE: Hi, everyone.
This is Stephan De
Barse with o9 Solutions.
At o9, we are digitally
transforming how businesses
plan and operate today.
I'm based out of Amsterdam.
I'm running o9 in
Europe, as well as
our global
go-to-market practice.
Today, we're going to talk about
AI-powered integrated business
spending on Google Cloud.
What is the agenda for today?
We'll start with a quick
introduction into o9 Solutions,
followed by the relevance of
planning in today's world,
where we'll share a couple of
learnings from the pandemic.
Then we will talk
about the architecture
of what we call the Future
Ready Enterprise, followed
by a couple of use cases in
retail and manufacturing.
Then we'll close out
with the key contacts,
so that you can engage
with us going forward.
What is o9 all about?
o9 is a premier AI platform for
integrated business planning
and digital operations.
We support companies in getting
to a more accurate forecast,
a faster response, and
end-to-end visibility.
The o9 platform is designed
for Fortune 500 companies.
We're working with leaders
in every single industry.
In retail, think about
Walmart and Starbucks,
where we help with forecasting
replenishment and integrated
flow planning.
In consumer products companies
like Nestlé and AB InBev,
as well as Estée Lauder.
We support those companies
in demand forecasting,
supply planning, and
integrated business planning.
Over the last few
years, the o9 platform
has been adopted by
many other leaders
in different industries, like
Exxon Mobil in oil and gas,
and T-Mobile in telecom.
Last but not least,
Google is an o9 client.
We are supporting
Google consumer hardware
in better predicting
demand, as well
as doing the supply planning and
integrated business planning.
Why are so many of those Fortune
500 companies selecting o9?
That is because we have
developed this next-generation
planning platform
that is able to cope
with the complexity
of organizations,
as well as using that technology
to help them better planning.
Then we have designed a UI and
UX that, from an enterprise
point of view, feels
like your Google
device or your
Google applications,
and hence, it is architected
to drive user adoption.
Lastly, time to value
is extremely important.
Our implementations are
short or fast and full
of very agile
implementation methodology.
What I want to do
with you next is share
a couple learnings
from this pandemic.
What have large retailers and
large manufacturers experienced
throughout the past
couple of months?
First, demand variability.
It's all about,
can I detect better
the risks and opportunities
on the demand side?
What we have seen is those
products mix shifts, right?
An increase in
essential products,
but a decrease in others.
Channel shifts, right?
Overnight, we went from the
traditional brick and mortar
to online.
We've also seen regional
demand variability,
with lockdown and reopening
schedules varying by country,
by city, in some
cases by zip code.
So the question is,
many organizations,
how do you now predict
demand when all of this
happens in a very
short amount of time?
That is a challenge
for many, and that
is something we support
global companies with.
Second is on the supply side.
Again, it's all about
early detection.
Many companies today do
not have the visibility
or the capacities, material
availability, and lead times
of their suppliers,
goal [? backers, ?]
or contract manufacturers.
What we have observed is that
supplies and suppliers are
slowing down or
stopping production,
but some are coming back online.
So how do I know on which
one I can rely, and when?
Right now, what we have seen
is that inventory and capacity
visibility across a
network is challenging.
There are multiple
ERPs, multiple systems,
and they don't have that
visibility quickly enough.
And then lastly, global
companies struggle
which visibility into
their supplier network.
So very often, they do not
know what suppliers can commit,
and what their capacities and
material availabilities are.
Third is integrated
planning and response.
How fast is an organization
able to run scenarios?
Demand can be 90, demand can
be 100, demand can be 110.
Well, what is my
supply chain response?
What is my true cost to serve?
And do I understand the
different assumptions
that go into those
different scenarios?
Companies today lack the ability
to run fast scenario planning,
understanding all the
different tradeoffs,
including the financial ones.
Again, that is something
where we provide support.
The other two key learnings is
that enterprise collaboration
goes digital.
What we have seen is
that whether companies
have production planners
or supply planners
or demand planners or
commercial planners, overnight,
all of those functions
had to work from home.
And what we've seen
is that that boosted
online and digital
collaboration,
but also showed the
possibilities of looking
into more centralized
and more specialized COEs
that companies can deploy.
Lastly, what we've seen is
digital operating models
for structural transformation.
CXOs that want
structural improvement
involve resilience and cost.
That means that this
whole collaboration
doesn't stop within the four
walls of the enterprise.
The question is, how
can we go beyond that
and start connecting with
suppliers and customers
in more real time, use that
knowledge to then shape demand,
and better collaborate
with suppliers and contract
manufacturers.
So we have observed a couple
of key trends, a couple
of key learnings, and
we have definitely
seen the need for
global companies
to digitally transform how
they do and execute integrated
business planning today.
Now, what I want to do
next is introduce you
to the o9 platform,
and I would like
to do that by using an
example from Google Maps.
In this example, Google is able
to tell us, hey, leave by 8:45
to arrive at the airport
one and a half hours
before your flight.
Now, we all take this kind
of technology for granted,
but to me, it's a
beautiful example
of how we have moved from sort
of traditional data and data
mining to prescriptive
decision making.
Now, let's take this
example to the enterprise.
Assume that we could sense
that demand is going up.
What do I instantly
want to understand?
Can I satisfy that
demand, yes or no?
If not, then I want
to understand why not.
Where are my constraints?
Is it a factory constraint,
a material constraint,
a logistics constraint?
But it doesn't
need to stop there.
What I truly want is a
prescriptive recommendation,
like Google Maps is giving
us here, and saying,
hey, I found out that
we have this logistics
constraint, but no worries--
we can set up an
expedited lane so you
can fulfill the demand on time.
Oh, and by the way,
the additional cost
of that expedite are X.
And that is the notion
of digital transformation
in the planning
space in the enterprise.
Now, what is actually
behind this example
that Google Maps is using?
Three core capabilities that
I will link to the enterprise
and to the o9
platform in a second.
In the middle,
you find something
that we call the
AI-powered knowledge model.
So in the Google Maps example,
there is network master data.
Think about the
map with the roads
and the traffic lights
and the speed limits.
That is obviously connected
with the big data store.
What do we find in
the big data store?
Location tracking,
calendar information,
and the flight status.
All those data elements
help us spotting risks
and opportunities much earlier.
So now, when you combine network
master data with big data
and you run smart algorithms,
now on your mobile device,
you can now receive prescriptive
actions with predictive alerts.
And again, that is where we
need to take enterprise decision
making, so that that becomes
as easy and as prescriptive
as this example
with Google Maps.
So at o9, we developed
the following platform
that allows us in
the transformation
to prescriptive decision making.
What you can see
in the middle is
what we call an
enterprise knowledge
graph, the digital
brain of the enterprise.
That is allowing us to create
a full digital representation
of the enterprise.
From the supply chain, the
supplier nodes, the material
hubs, the factories
to the shippers,
connecting that with
the different demand
nodes, the products,
the initiatives,
the sales accounts-- all the way
to the go-to-market channels,
whether it's selling
through retail, business
to business, or to
stores or online,
ultimately all the way
down to the end consumer,
where we can also bring in
data from the competitor.
So that entire
knowledge brain is then
connected with
various data sensors.
What kind of data sensors?
Think about your ERP, where
we connect with master
data and transactional data.
But more importantly,
we want to connect
with data that gives us insights
in risks and opportunities,
so we can connect with
external data sources,
both structured and
unstructured from nature.
Can I give a couple of examples?
Absolutely.
Think about a company like
AB InBev, the largest beer
company in the world.
They're selling
through retail, they're
selling online, and
through distribution.
What is driving their demand?
Think about weather.
Think about competitive pricing.
Think about competitive
promotions, their own trade
promotions, their
marketing initiatives.
So what if we could
collect all the data
and use that more intelligently
to forecast the demand?
Other example-- Starbucks.
What is driving their demand?
Think about local events--
a football game, or
maybe a graduation event,
when a Starbucks store is
located on a university campus.
Again, weather is
also a big influencer
in terms of what's driving
demand at Starbucks.
So again, it's about
capturing that information
and bringing that in.
Is that only happening
with consumer products?
Not really.
Think about companies like
Pirelli Tires or Bridgestone
Tires.
They're selling tires
to dealers and OEMs.
What is driving their demand?
That could be, you
know, the number of cars
being produced by the OEMs.
Can we incorporate
that kind of data?
And again, the answer is yes.
So the entire notion is, we are
looking out for all those data
sources that can either
predict a demand risk
or opportunity or a supply
risk and opportunity,
and integrate that
with the digital brain.
Then on top of the
digital brain is
where we expose different
planning workflows.
On the far left hand side,
it's all about joint customer
collaboration, as well as better
connecting with my account
sales teams, category
management, and product
portfolio management.
Then when I jump into
the enterprise again,
that is where my commercial
teams are connected
with my customers, and that is
where we need to support them
with annual operating planning,
initiative planning, demand
planning, gap closure
planning, and all
that combined with
analytics, because planning
and analytics go hand in hand.
On the same platform,
that is where you
can do supply chain planning.
We are creating a full digital
twin of the supply chain,
providing end-to-end
visibility and allowing
for smart and intelligent demand
supply matching, control tower
capabilities, and
scenario planning.
Obviously we want
to connect that
with suppliers and
contract manufacturers,
as well as with all your
factories and logistics
operators.
Then, similar to the commercial
side, planning and analytics
go hand in hand, which means
I can run analytics on my cost
to serve, inventory,
different planning policies,
and so forth.
So all of this is
then coming together
in the sales and
operations planning.
No more meetings and PowerPoint.
It's fact-based decisions
live in the platform
where, again, the
system will prescribe
what actions to take
based on running
the different scenarios.
Now, all of this is obviously
across time horizons,
so from the daily planning--
you know, the next
four weeks out--
all the way to the long range
planning, the next five years
out.
And that is a true
differentiator
of the o9 platform.
On top of that, the
entire architecture
has been built to be
open source, which
means that we can integrate
with R, Python, Gurobi,
and the likes so that any
development that you have
made in data science already
can be leveraged in o9 platform.
What I want to do
next is summarize
what we have discussed.
So in o9, it all comes together
in this enterprise knowledge
graph.
You should truly see this
as the intelligent brain
of your enterprise that is
connected, on the left hand
side, with your
transactional backbone.
We connect with your [? UP ?]
system, your CRM systems,
your PLM systems, and so forth.
But also, we have this
integration framework
that I just mentioned with R,
Python, Gurobi, and the links.
And then obviously, at large
scale organizations like
Walmart or like Nestlé
or like AB InBev,
there is a need for being future
proof in terms of having big
data capabilities, and that is
where we are integrated with
Hadoop and Hive.
On the right hand side,
you see that is where all
those different data sources--
internal and external,
structured and unstructured
data--
are coming into the brain, where
o9 takes care of data cleansing
and data harmonization.
Ultimately, we offer
[INAUDIBLE] best in class
UI to tablet browser mobile
to the different users
in the enterprise.
Now, obviously, o9 9
is born in the cloud
and natively deployed
on Google Cloud,
and that is also
how we can scale
for and with our global clients.
Next are a couple of examples.
Where has o9 been
implemented, and what is
the value that we are logging?
Now, first and foremost,
Google consumer hardware.
What happened,
actually, prior to o9?
Actually, a legacy
system in Excel.
What we identified was the
supply chain cost and inventory
were quite high,
as well as there
were complexities in managing
the end-to-end supply chain.
Now, with the o9 platform,
Google consumer hardware
is able to make better
decisions to reduce inventory
and to reduce
non-standard supply chain
costs, such as flex capacity
expedites and so forth.
At Estée Lauder, we are
replacing SAP APO at a global
scale for demand planning,
for supply planning,
for integrated
business planning.
One of the unique issues at
Estée is that their product
portfolio changes very
rapidly, and hence,
there is a need to better plan
for new product introductions,
but also to link that to
the supply chain to minimize
solvence risks for products that
you're going to take out with
the shelves.
Two other examples would
be in the retail space--
Starbucks and Walmart.
What are we replacing
at Starbucks?
JDA plus lot of spreadsheets.
What was really the
issue at Starbucks
is that the barista in the store
is spending way too much time
on inventory, on admin
work, on ordering,
and Starbucks wants that barista
to spend time with the client.
The other issue is
that there is a lot
of demand variability driven
by weather, local events,
and so forth.
So what we did, we actually
built an AI-powered forecasting
model, taking into consideration
weather data, promotional data,
external events data,
and predicting the demand
at [? SKU-store ?] level, while
at the same time linking that
in an automated fashion to
the replenishment so that
the barista can spend time
on serving your and me,
rather than doing ordering
and inventory and so forth.
At Walmart, we are deploying
a solution for integrated flow
planning.
In other words, how do I take
my products from my inbound DCs
to the shelf in the most
efficient and optimal way,
taking into consideration all
the different constraints,
the cost, and the complexities
of a network that consists
of a million SKUs, four
and a half thousand stores,
and 200-plus DCs.
Prior to o9, Walmart was not
able to run a full constraint
plan, which with o9,
they are, as well as they
can run different scenarios
to understand tradeoffs
between improving on-shelf
availability and cost.
So what is the impact of o9?
Let me give you two examples.
At a large retailer where we
implemented the o9 platform,
we were able to improve
the forecast accuracy,
improve the service
level, and in reality,
reduce expediting cost for
both labor and transportation.
Another example would be a
large industrial manufacturing
company, where we implement
demand, supply, and inventory.
And we've seen
tremendous improvements
in forecast accuracy,
inventory reduction,
as well as a significant
improvement in service level
and a reduction in expediting
and transportation costs.
So what we believe is that for
every billion dollars in sales,
there is a $10 to 20
million value opportunity
when companies decide
to implement o9.
Now, if you want to
hear more about o9,
about some use cases,
or about anything
else around our platform
you can contact me directly
or our Google client
account lead, Simon Baksys.
Thank you very much, and
wishing you a wonderful day.